Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has made his way to the G7 here in
Hiroshima where leaders from around the
world are set to discuss how to best
help Ukraine against Russia now
zielinski has two missions while he's
here the first one get more weapons from
G7 countries the US are likely to send a
fresh round of supplies to Ukraine and
the Americans have already agreed to
allow Allied countries to send them F-16
fighter jets something Joe Biden has
previously resisted now Ukrainian Pilots
would need to be trained so that's not
going to help with the upcoming
counter-offensive but both the
Netherlands and the UK said they're
working to get them those aircrafts now
zelinsky's other goal is going to be to
try to increase the Coalition of leaders
willing to help him out with a
particular focus on countries that
diplomats are calling swing States and
the most important which is India Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi has not
publicly so far condemned Russia's
Invasion now Modi recently actually
visited with President Vladimir Putin of
Russia and the two said they had an
unbreakable friendship but if zielinski
can break that Bond it really could be a
game changer in the war now the
Ukrainian Leader's visit has really
thrown a wrench into the planning of the
summit the G7 leaders announced
communicate a final day early and it
talked about a myriad of issues
including how the block wants to handle
China the Declaration says that each
country will act in their own National
interest in dealing with Beijing but
they'll push back against China slapping
trade measures on countries they're in
disagreements with the communique also
calls on trying to follow conventions
around Diplomat activities and not
interfere in the Democratic process and
that's a topic a Canadian senior
officials said Justin Trudeau raised
yesterday at a Leader's dinner the Prime
Minister also announced that nearly half
billion dollars in funding mainly to
help countries build infrastructure and
improve food security and that's what
true to discussed today when he left
with the leaders of Vietnam and
Indonesia but the big bilat is coming
tomorrow when it's likely expected Mr
Trudeau will be meeting with Mr
zielinski Mackenzie gray Global News
Hiroshima Japan